a popular stretch of beaches in
Massachusetts will remain close to
swimming today because of a deadly
weekend shark attack 26 year old arthur
medici died saturday after being bitten
by a shark it was the first deadly shark
attack in Massachusetts in more than 80
years the attack happened on a stretch
of the Cape Cod National Seashore
visitors are being told to stay out of
the water
Nicky batiste is in Wellfleet
Massachusetts near the scene of the
attack Nicky good morning good morning
on Saturday around noon arthur medici
and his friend were riding waves on
their boogie boards about 30 yards out
into this water right off this Cape Cod
Shore that's when one witness says he
saw what looked like a 10 to 12-foot
shark attack Medici Waldman was just
going like this waving to us and I ran
up more than a dozen beachgoers on Cape
Cod Saturday scrambled to help carry
arthur medici to safety after he was
bitten on both legs by a shark let's
bring it back up the beach screaming
like a lunatic call 9-1-1 has been a
shark attack a report of an unknown
shark bite medici was rushed to a nearby
hospital where he was later pronounced
dead isaac rota was in the water near
medici when the attack happened he says
he and the victim were like brothers
he was screaming and then uh I saw like
a shark trailer and I swam him fastest I
couldn't have moment I dragged him back
to shore and I got a boogie board
strapped and I turn around to the side
to try to stop the bleeding saturday's
shark attack is at least the second on
Cape Cod this summer in August sixty
one-year-old bill Linton survived after
being bitten by a shark after two
attacks I think we can be concerned that
it's a dangerous situation we see these
sharks every day along this coastline
they are there in big numbers and and
people have to be vigilant and be aware
of it Greg skomal is a marine biologist
for the state of Massachusetts he
believes the shark likely mistook Medici
for a seal which are often close to
shore along Cape Cod's beaches and as a
result these sharks are coming as close
as they possibly can without risking
their own lives to try to kill and eat
the
seals and and that creates a bit of a
problem because that's exactly where
people are utilizing the shoreline and
so you know this is something we're
looking at it's something we're trying
to advise swimmers about so that this
does not happen again the National Park
Service is warning people on Cape Cod to
not swim with the seals and we've seen a
few seals just a few yards offshore here
this morning while shark attacks are
rare last year one study says there were
53 unprovoked shark attacks in the u.s.
that's more than any other country in
the world
John Nikki thanks